[Música]
Olá,
boa noite meus amigos, minhas amigas. É
um prazer muito grande estar aqui com
vocês para mais uma live. Boa noite
Matias Dormício, Cleidan, Antônio
Renato, por favor, me de retorno se tá
tudo OK com áudio. OK,
vocês estão me ouvindo bem?
Eu vou aguardar o retorno para
continuar.
OK, ótimo. Perfeito. Vamos continuar
então aqui temos várias perguntas para
responder, inclusive, deixa eu só ver se
vou verificar se chegou perguntas novas
aqui nesse intervalo.
E deem só um instante.
Não, não chegou. Primeira pergunta,
deixa eu mostrar na tela.
Doutor Alan, você gosta da terapêutica
de bicarbonato de sódio para câncer e
paraa manutenção da saúde em pessoa
saudável? Se pratica posologia
como devemos usar para pacientes de
câncer e para pessoas saudáveis. Atecipo
agradecimentos.
Bem, vamos lá.
Essa história do bicarbonato
tem duas visões. Eu vou dar primeiro a
visão oficial e a minha visão, OK?
Pela visão oficial, isso não é
respaldado pela literatura científica
internacional. Não tem comprovação de
que o uso do bicarbonato possa alterar o
ambiente tumoral para quem tem câncer de
uma maneira relevante ou que traga
benefício clínico direto em pacientes
oncológicos.
Então, o bicarbonato sódio, dentro da
visão oficial pode ser útil em quadros
específicos de acidose metabólica. Aí
vai ser feito endovenoso
nesses casos em hospital e não é um uso
domiciliar e nem oral, mas uso rotineiro
via oral em grandes doses supostamente
poderia causar riscos importantes como a
alcalose metabólica que é o excesso de
álcalis no sangue que é o exess que é o
contrário de acidose metabólica
sobrecarga de sódio, retenção de
líquido, descompensação do coração. Isso
principalmente pessoas já têm problemas
como cardíacos ou renais.
No caso de pessoas saudáveis, pela visão
oficial, também não haveria indicação do
uso regular de bicarbonato de sódio para
prevenção de câncer ou de outras doenças
crônicas, porque o equilíbrio ácido
básico do corpo, ele é rigidamente
controlado por mecanismos fisiológicos,
tema tampão.
Então, existe sim o uso pontual, né, em
algumas estratégicas naturais para
higiene bucal, controle sintomático de
aia,
mas tem que ser com moderação para não
exagerar na dose.
Então agora a minha visão, tá? Eu acho
que a dieta alcalina
com vegetais é muito interessante
para o câncer, especialmente para
prevenção e tratamento do câncer. Então,
quando você come bastante vegetal, você
acaba comendo mais magnésio. E essa
quantidade maior de magnésio, de
potássio também, de zinco, de fósforo,
de vários minerais, vai ajudar eh na
questão do sistema tampão do organismo.
O que acontece é que tem muita confusão
em relação à questão de alcalinidade.
Tem muita gente que vende aí protocolos
de alcalinização, etc.
Só que assim, você tem que entender que
o organismo tem vários compartimentos.
O sangue ele fica numa faixa muito
estreita de pH, 7.35 a 745.
E se a pessoa comer um excesso de ácidos
na alimentação,
que que acontece? O osso acaba mandando
magnésio pro sangue para compensar.
Então você tem uma perda de magnésio
pelo osso e muitas vezes o cálcio também
é mobilizado junto. Então quando a gente
fala de alcalinidade, de acidez, a gente
tem que pensar nos vários
compartimentos. Você tem o sangue, você
tem o o tecido celular, eh, intestício,
dentro da célula, dentro da saliva, na
urina,
todos os líquidos corporais que nós
temos. Então é muito complicado esse
assunto, não é uma coisa simplícita como
muita gente faz crer, que é só você
comer alimentos alcalinos que você vai
alcalinizar o sangue. Isso não existe,
porque o sangue realmente fica nessa
faixa que eu falei.
Então sim, dieta alcalina é muito boa
pro organismo porque ela preserva o
buffer, o tampão do osso que é consumido
quando você não come álcool suficiente
na alimentação. Agora, bicarbonato, no
meu ponto de vista,
ele pode ajudar sim, mas não é uma coisa
que eu recomendaria que vocês fizessem
por conta própria, assim, sem
orientação. Por exemplo, uma uma vez eu
usei o bicarbonato para evitar a questão
de
aquela sensação excessiva, né, de
cansaço muscular pós atividade física de
musculação. que quando você faz a
musculação, você desenvolve um pouco de
acidose em no tecido muscular por conta
do ácido lático e fica dolorido. Então,
nesses casos, eu usei o bicarbonato para
dar uma diminuída nessa questão da
acidose do músculo, mas paraa questão de
câncer eu acredito que não seja
realmente uma coisa muito efetiva, tá?
Mas eu acho que eu vou fazer o quê? Eu
vou fazer um vídeo exclusivo pro canal
sobre esse assunto,
só pros apoiadores. Eu vou eu vou fazer
um vídeo, eu vou fazer uma pesquisa mais
aprofundada sobre isso. E por favor, me
cobrem no grupo, tá? Me cobrem para não
esquecer, mas eu quero fazer um vídeo
sobre esse assunto. Eu quero fazer um
levantamento mais apurado da literatura
para falar desse assunto. OK? Vamos pra
próxima pergunta, tá? Patrícia me cobre
depois, tá?
Dout. Quan eh quem tem osteopenia ou
osteoporose pode utilizar K2 como
adivante ou coadvante? Sim, pode e deve,
tá? A K2 ele é o GPS do cálcio. Ele vai
ajudar a colocar o cálcio no osso e não
acumular esse cálcio na parede da
artéria ou nos tecidos moles.
A K2 MK7 ele vai ajudar na ativação de
uma proteína chamada osteocalcina.
que vai fixar o cálcio na matriz óssea,
então ajuda a prevenir deposição nos
vasos, promove melhor qualidade de
óssea, tem vários estudos que comprovam
isso e auxiliando, desculpa, e
associando com, como vocês já sabem, que
eu já falei em lives anteriores, mas tem
gente nova hoje aqui, eu acho,
associando a vitamina D3, associando ao
cálcio e associando ao magnésio. Então,
esses três elementos D3, cálcio,
magnésio mais H2 vão ser muito
importantes para saúde óssea,
ok?
E eu já falei isso em lives anteriores,
a K2 é muito segura para uso. Você pode
estar usando entre 100 e 200 microg ao
dia tranquilamente.
Vamos pra próxima.
Existe maneira de reativar a função
tiroideia
e não ter de tomar T4, mas T3 para
sempre? Existe. Acho que is que de não,
já coloquei respondido aqui. Existe sim,
existe maneira sim, tá? Como é que você
reativa a função tiroide? Primeiro
combatendo a doença de base, então que
90% das vezes é doença de rashimoto.
Então você combate a doença de
rashimoto, né? A tiroide de rashimoto
através do quê? através de
mudar a alimentação, cortar os alimentos
processados, industrializados,
refinados, o glúten, leite derivados
para a barreira intestinal ficar
recuperada. E ao recuperar a barreira
intestinal, você resolve o liquigante.
Ao resolver o liquigante, você evita de
acontecer aquele vazamento de proteínas
estranhas paraa circulação sanguínea no
intestino. E dessa maneira você eh está
deixando de alimentar a autoimunidade,
deixando de alimentar o rachimoto.
Então, nesses casos,
você consegue sim reverter o rachimoto e
se não houve lesão tecidual suficiente,
você consegue reverter a doença e voltar
a reativar a função tiroideia. Aí você
pode usar vários nutrientes também para
ajudar nesse processo, o selênio, o
zinco, o cobre, o ferro, se tiver
deficiência de ferro, vitamina B12, o
complexo B de modo geral, a própria
vitaminaado,
então o iodo, todos esses elementos,
eles vão ajudar a recuperar a tireoide,
tá? O betaglucana também ajuda, tá?
Então tem vários elementos que aí pode
ajudar a elitirosina que é o aminoácido
que ajuda a formar o hormônio tirodiano.
Então tem vários nutrientes que podem
ajudar. OK? Eu acho que eu respondi,
é, se vocês tiverem mais alguma dúvida,
mas eu já respondi essa pergunta aqui na
totalidade. Ah, só um instantinho.
Vamos continuar. Doutor, mandei
manipular sua fórmula para varizes.
Diosmina, esperidina, rosa, canina.
E mais quatro itens. Pode ser tomado de
forma contínua uma dose por dia ou
precisa interromper o uso de tempos em
tempos. Me dê só um instante que eu tô
com mensagem urgente aqui.
Aí, vamos responder tua pergunta.
Bem, sem acompanhamento médico, a
resposta curta é não. Não faça uso
contínuo sem acompanhamento médico.
Então, se você não consegue passar em
consulta com ninguém, é melhor você
parar de usar depois de 90 dias, ok?
Porém, se você conseguir acompanhamento,
você pode estar utilizando por 6 meses
ou mais.
É bem seguro, mas como você não vai
estar em acompanhamento, às vezes você
tem azar de ter uma alergia de de ter
algum problema,
ã, então é melhor você não fazer uso
sozinha por mais de 90 dias,
tá? Mas tem muita gente que toma
diosmina com espiridina durante muito
tempo e não tem nenhum tipo de reação,
ok? É só pra gente ficar do lado seguro
da situação.
Vamos pra próxima.
Dr. Alan, me identifiquei com o vídeo do
lítio orotato. Talvez essa cereja do
bolo que me falta. Usar o lítio orotato
na concentração de 5 mg ao dia seria a
mesma coisa que consumir água rica em
lítio?
Ah, depende do que água rica em lítio,
né?
Porque a água rin liquid vai ter entre
01 e 03 mg por litro. Então é uma dose
muito muito baixa.
Se você consumir essa água, digamos por
muitos anos, vai ter um efeito
preventivo. Mas o litiorotata, a dose é
muito mais alta, é 5 mg por dia, apesar
de ser ainda microdosagem.
No caso, se você não tem depressão, não
tem nenhum tipo de estudo psiquiátrico,
você pode até tomar água com lítio se a
tua intenção fosse só prevenção. Agora,
se você já quer tratar uma depressão,
algo assim, eu não usaria essa água,
usaria o lítio orotato na forma de
suplemento de 5 a 10 mg por dia, tá?
Então, água com rica em lítio poderia
ser uma uma alternativa para prevenção
para pessoas que não tm nenhum tipo de
sintoma.
Não sei o sobre o que perguntar. Se que
é boa
a pergunta é uma meta pergunta.
[Risadas]
Engraçado isso aí. Vamos lá, vamos
continuar aqui.
Não sei se você está acompanhando os
tratamentos experimentais com altas
doses de vermectina. Sim, eu tô
acompanhando sim,
acompanhando e fazendo também. vários
pacientes tomando isso daí. Mas caso
você conheça sobre o assunto, eu
gostaria de perguntar se você já ouviu
falar sobre o paciente de ter sono pós
utilização.
Sim, alguns pacientes me falaram que
sentiram fadiga tomando isso. Daí é um
efeito colateral que eu escutei, sim. Ã,
algumas pessoas também falaram que tava
com distorções do campo visual, tava
tendo flashes no na visão ou então perda
de visão, não perda de visão, mas piora
da visão noturna, tá? Então, escutei
esses principais efeitos aí dos mectino,
mas geralmente são temporários, tá?
São efeitos temporários. Bem, vamos pro
próximo. Dr. Alão, o ômega3 da Vitafor
Mega DHA 120 cápsulas tem 1500 em casa.
100 em casa. Cápsulas. Quantas cápsulas
você comenta tomar por dia de forma
segura? Duas. duas cápsulas por dia, tá
bom?
Porque ele tem um te, geralmente a dose
que eles colocam lá como a dose do
serving, né, que seria o o
tanto que recomenda, eh duas cápsulas
por dia, que vai ter a quantidade
adequada do produto.
Mas se você tiver
ah tiver tomando só por conta de
prevenção, não tiver nenhum problema
neurológico, você pode até tomar uma
cápsula por dia, tá?
Não haveria problema de tomar somente
uma não se fosse só prevenção.
Dr. Alan, se uma pessoa tem problemas
nos insada
ou grave, se ela fizer a dieta
cetogênica radical, ela pode ajudar em
todos os cenários ou não? O que que é
cetogênica radical? Porque ou você faz a
dieta cetogênica ou não faz, tá? Radical
aí seria fazer direito, é isso? Que
cetogênica tem que formar copos
cetônicos. Se não tiver formando um copo
cetô, isso não é dieta cetogênica. Então
eu acho que tá querendo dizer dieta
cetogênica,
eh, que seja feita de uma maneira
adequada, né? Eu acho que é isso que tá
querendo dizer.
Então, eh, pra maioria das pessoas, a
cetogênica, ela vai ser uma dieta
altamente anti-inflamatória, mas eu tô
falando da cetogênica bem feita, que
você come vegetais
coloridos, que você tem uma grande
variedade de vegetais na dieta, que você
come gordura saudável, aí sim ela é
altamente antiinflamatória e ela pode
ajudar bastante na maioria das doenças,
tá?
Por que que acontece o seguinte? A
pessoa que tá eh comendo excesso de
carboidratos e tá com resistência
insulínica, a célula não consegue
aproveitar todo a glicose que tá
disponível no sangue. Então sobra
glicose no sangue que não é aproveitada
pela célula e essa glicose começa a
glicar, começa a caramelizar as
proteínas do sangue e aumentar o a taxa
de envelhecimento, aumentar a inflamação
crônica. Então, a acetogênica ela é
muito eh terapêutica, apesar de ser uma
dieta difícil de seguir a longo prazo,
tá? Então, uma dieta muito boa para você
fazer durante 3 a 6 meses para se curar
de algum problema e depois você volta
por uma dieta mais tranquila, né? Uma
dieta mais low carb, em vez de fazer uma
dieta cetogênica o resto da vida que é
difícil de seguir. OK?
Então, eu não sei bem o que você quis
dizer com radical. Se você tiver, acho
que você tá ao vivo, né, Antônio? Deixa
eu olhar aqui, depois você explica para
mim o que que é radical, que eu não sei
se eu entendi. Eh, eu tô entendendo como
uma dieta
e bem feita, né? Não sei se é isso você
tá querendo dizer.
Hum. Dra. Ana Paula tá fazendo os
comentários aqui. Dra. Paula hoje tá
bastante comunicativa.
Boa noite a todos. Eu creio que
misturaram mais coisas do que deveria.
da Flon que deos mina, não sei o que lá.
Sim, ela prescreve durante anos, mas eu
não recomendo que tome sozinho sem
acompanhamento.
Tã.
E nem Ah, ela tá falando aqui, nem todo
mundo que usa ivet tem diarreia. Sim,
tem gente que tem, mas a maioria não tem
diarreia não.
Hum.
Pessoal, evitem de fazer perguntas ao
vivo, tá? Se der tempo, eu vou
responder, mas ultimamente tem tido
muita pergunta do documento.
Então a diastetogênica pode sim ajudar,
né, em boa parte das doenças renais
crônicas, mas não em todas, tá?
Ah, Dra. Balance uma paciente mulher que
vai se consultar com você. Ela faz os
exames que você pediu, mas além deles
ela deseja acrescentar ultrassom total
para identificar miomas,
já que ela já fez anteriormente e deu
miomas. Ela quer mostrar para você. Pode
pode, não entendi porque que tá
perguntando isso. Não. Você só pede os
exames após a consulta online ou quando
a pessoa marca. A gente tem as as duas
maneiras, tá? Tem paciente que só faz
exame depois que passa e tem faz exame
pronto antes, tá? As duas maneiras
existem, OK?
E sim, ela pode apresentar qualquer
exame que ela tenha. Não vou deixar de
ver os exames só porque supostamente o
exame não é da minha especialidade. Se é
isso que você tá querendo dizer, eu não
sei se eu entendi exatamente o que você
quis dizer, mas eu acho que tá tem tá
pensando que eu não vou ver o trassom
porque não é da minha especialidade
alguma coisa assim, né? Porque é um
trassom ginecológico. Sim, eu vou ver,
eu vejo os exames todos. Sim.
Tá bom.
Boa noite. Gostaria de saber se Red
Rice, que é o monsticos purpúrios,
elimina o ferro.
Se elimina o ferro?
Essa pergunta eu não nunca escutei.
Que eu saiba não, eu não vi nenhuma
evidência na literatura que o monascos
purpúrios, que é um tipo de estatina
natural, vai fazer esse efeito aí de
queelar ferro.
Nunca vi isso em lugar nenhum,
porque ela faz enemia hmg redutas, a
hidróximil glutaril com enzima a reduto,
que é a enzima que faz parte da via do
mevalonato.
E ao inibir essa enzima, ela vai
diminuir a cinese hepática de
colesterol,
né?
Mas ela não mexe com ferro, que eu saibo
não.
Você viu aonde? Se você tiver ao vivo,
Luciane,
você pode me dizer onde que você viu
essa informação?
Eh, para dormir tomo 332
mg de magnésio bisglicinato, mesma
quantidade, às 10 horas da manhã.
Pouco, mas não consigo mais que isso.
Blend de ervilha e arroz 30 g. Essa vai
interferir no magnésio, tá? Não é Whey,
né? É um pó de ervilha e arroz, né? Não,
não vai interferir, não fica sossegado.
Magnésio vai continuar sendo absorvido
porque o bislicinato é totalmente
biodisponível, ele tem um mecanismo
específico de absorção através do
aminoácido e não tem essa interação
relevante com as proteínas vegetais. OK?
O que pode atrapalhar é o consumo
concomitante de alimentos ricos em
cálcio, o excesso de fibras que pode
atrapalhar o magnésio, tá? Mas não é o
caso desse pau proteico não.
E vai ajudar no seu sono, com certeza.
Ã T4 na live, 7 de novembro.
Não entendi isso não. T4 na live 7 de
novembro. Ah, 7 de novembro 24. Tá. Tem
uma pergunta que vitamina C ajuda no T4,
mas não tinha pesquisa sobre T3 que
geralmente se toma junto. Já já mudou
isso? Posso tomar o T4, T3, vitamina C
junto um ano depois?
Sim. Eh, existe essa evidência de que a
vitamina C potencializa a absorção de
T4,
então pode ajudar.
E eu não conheço ainda informações sobre
o T3, tá? continua a mesma coisa.
Eu acho que não teria nenhum problema se
tomar ao mesmo tempo T4, T3 e a vitamina
C. Lógico que não pode também associar
outras coisas, só esses três, tá? No
magnésio tomado às 10 horas da manhã,
posso tomar o curco flex, cigar do diabo
e bzo velha juntos? Sim, pode. Estou
lembrando de uma colher de gordura
junto.
Sim. Não vejo problema nenhum você fazer
isso, não. Tá. Inclusive o magnésio vai
ajudar na dor muscular, né? Então essa
associação é boa. Então a gordura ela
vai ajudar na absorção dos princípios
ativos da cúrcuma e da bozuélia. Só
seria a contraindicação se você tivesse
dor de estômago, tá? que incomodasse
essa associação. Aí
quando estou quase aquela queimação no
estômago, tomo 200 ml de água, algumas
gotas de limão, meia colher de
bicarbonato. Em minutos não sinto mais
nada. Isso pode ser a falta o excesso de
ácido clorídrico no estômago. Tá dizendo
então que
o limão e o bicarbonato
e tá meio confuso aqui. Que que tá dando
azinho em você? É o é antes e que
melhora com o limão ou é um limão que tá
te dando queimação? Eu tô entendendo
aqui que o limão tá ajudando na
queimação. Pelo jeito você tá colocando
aqui algumas gotas de limão e meia
colher de bicarbonato. Bicarbonato ele
vai anular a acidez do do limão, né? Mas
eu acho que você tá interessado é mais
na vitamina C e dos minerais que tem no
limão, né? Bem, se o bicarbonato tá
ajudando é porque tá, digamos, tá
bloqueando a acidez do estômago, tá?
Porque o bicarbonato ele tá
neutralizando o ácido de estômago. Então
você poderia fazer um teste, por
exemplo, tomar só o limão sem o
bicarbonato e ver que acontece e usar só
o bicarbonato sem limão também. faz os
testes aí, mas eu acho que o que tá te
dando o bem-estar aí é o bicarbonato. E
assim, eh, nem sempre a causa da
gastrite excesso de, aliás, na minoria
das vezes é a causa da gastrite é a
mucosa do estômago que tá enfraquecida,
tá inflamada por conta de uma
alimentação inadequada, o excesso de
café, excesso de álcool ou até mesmo o
efeito do glúten do leite, tá? existe a
possibilidade de um efeito rebote. Aí,
por exemplo, se você ficar utilizando
muito bicarbonato, o corpo vai compensar
a produção de ácido para tentar bloquear
o bicarbonato e vai cada vez mais
aumentar o ácido no estômago. E se a
mucosa es tiver irritada pode doer, tá?
Esse que seria o problema. Então, tomar
cuidado com isso.
Seria interessante você cicatrizar essa
mucosa com aloe vera, com licorice dgl,
com caldo de osso, com gengibre. tá
com
as encarnos esse tipo de coisa.
Idoso que retirou a próstata alguns
meses atrás no exame recente de PSA
ainda está alterado.
Continuar com suplementos como super
prostate, que é da Life extension, São
Pmeto, Sting Nero eu nunca sei
pronunciar é Nerow. Não sei se é narrow
ou narle, mas deve ser narrow. Sting
narrow extract pump pumping oil zinc
tomato extract. Selen Excel pode ajudar
alguma outra recomendação?
Não seria o caso, tá? Porque você falou
que retirou a próstata
e você não tá explicando aqui se foi
câncer ou não foi câncer,
mas tá dando a entender que é porque que
é câncer, porque da tela forma que no
exame recente tá alterado, né? Então tá
bem ambígua a pergunta, certo?
Mas se for realmente um câncer, não vai
ser esse produtos aí que vai resolver a
recidiva do câncer, tá?
Porque se foi uma próstatectomia
radical, o PSA tem que tá indetectável
menor de 0,05.
Se ainda tá aumentando ou ou tá
detectável, provavelmente a pessoa vai
ter que fazer tratamentos eh adicionais
com radioterapia ou bloqueio hormonal,
tá? além de poder tomar vários
suplementos
anticâncer, mas não é bem essa sequência
que você tá colocando aí, não, tá? O
salmeto para um paciente que tirou a
próstata
próstatactomia radical para câncer não
vai ser útil nesse momento.
O extrato de óleo de semente abóbora
pode ser útil, o zinco pode ser útil,
mas eh o protocolo tem que ser mais
intenso do que isso aí, tá?
Às vezes tem que fazer um pet scan para
ver se tá tendo metáse a distância, tá?
Eu acessaria o tratamento ortodoxo com
tratamento natural, as duas coisas.
Aí que que poderia utilizar? Poderia
utilizar suforafano, quecetina, bzo
serrata, curcumina,
ômega-3.
Tem um monte de coisa dá para fazer se
for um câncer estivado, tá? Então a
pergunta não tá clara, mas eu tô
entendendo que a pessoa possa est câncer
ou tratou o câncer, né, com a
próstatectomia radical.
Doutor Alan, estou com alguns sintomas
de falta de testosterona. No meu exame
de sangue, a testosterona total e níveis
estão altas, mas o SHBG também. Quando o
SHBG é alto, a reposição hormonal pode
ajudar?
Sim. O SHPG, se você fizer uso de
testosterona
injetável, ele SHBG ele cai, tá? Então
um dos jeitos de fazer a reposição de
testosterona é com injeção, tanto
intramuscular quanto subcutâneo.
Tem gente que, por exemplo, faz uso da
testosterona subcutânea, tipo 0,2 ml por
dia. Pode usar também em ml duas vezes
semana se fosse pionato testosterona.
E nesses casos HBG vai cair quando você
usa a testosterona
injetável. Agora o transdica não não
mexe no SHVG não. Então se a pessoa
tiver usando a testosterona
transdérêmica,
tem que primeiro entender que porque que
esse SHBG tá alto. Às vezes ele tá alto
para tentar compensar.
A vida ele tá alto por conta de
organismo tentando compensar excesso de
um outro hormônio. Mas digamos que não
seja isso, seja uma questão de fígado,
tem que ver porque que o fígado tá
produzindo muito esse HBG. Às vezes é
algum problema hepático também, tá?
Então, antes de sair batendo esse HBG, a
melhor coisa é investigar porque que a
SH HBG tá alto,
tá? Eu vou falar aqui algumas causas de
SHBG, hipotiroidismo,
sobrepeso, disbiose intestinal,
uso de alguns medicamentos
e muitas vezes só emagrecendo e tirando
os alimentos inflamatórios,
você consegue baixar já o SKBG
ou tratando o hipotiroidismo, tá?
Hoje em dia vídeos de médicos muito
considerados que indípulos de
bicarbonato que teria efeitos muito bons
na saúde geral da pessoa. Caso seja isso
mesmo, existe alguma maneira de pessoas
que tm hipocloridria
também fazer uso dele?
Sim, se a pessoa quer usar bicarbonato,
ela pode utilizar contanto que ela tome
bicarbonato fora dos horários das
refeições, porque ela vai ter que usar
um cloridade betaína durante a refeição
e aí ela pode tomar o bicarbonato fora
do horário da refeição, tá? Porque você
tomar durante a refeição vai bloquear o
efeito do ácido no estômago, pelo menos
temporariamente.
OK?
Vamos pro próximo.
A quantidade del proteína por dia para
que em prática exercício físico é de 1,4
a 2,2 mg 2 a 1,4 a 2,2 gg.
Essa quantidade é só de proteína animal?
Não é proteína em geral. Eh, a soma de
todas as proteínas, tá? Vou dar meu
exemplo. Consumo é 1,8 g de proteína
animal, mas não um somo com que eu
consumo de proteína vegetal.
Então é que você tem que fazer a conta.
Você pensa provavelmente que 100 g de
carne tem 100 g de proteína. Não é. Não
é assim. É mais ou menos metade de um
bife é é proteína. E a mesma coisa, os
vegetais também pode ter menos proteína,
mas também tem. Então você tem que fazer
a conta, você tem que buscar aplicativos
igual cronômeter, não é de cronômetro de
relógio, não é, mas chama assim o
aplicativo. É um aplicativo muito bom
que você pode calcular os macros. Tem
outros no Brasil semelhantes. Então você
pode baixar um aplicativo desse,
colocará lá quantas gramas de de tais
alimentos que tá comendo, ele vai
calcular quanto tem de proteína em cada
alimento e vai te dar a conta lá, tá?
Então, recapitulando,
100 g de carne não é igual a 100 g de
proteína. Assim como 100 g de arroz, não
tem zero de proteína, tem a tem proteína
no arroz, por exemplo, tá?
É óbvio que a proteína animal vai ter
melhor biodisponibilidade, mas a vegetal
também é absorvida, tá?
Quero tentar absorver magnésio. Deve ser
absorver, né? Através dos pés. Qual o
melhor tipo? Qual a quantidade colocar?
Ã,
isso vai ser individual, tá? Porque não
sei como é que é a questão da sua pele
em termos de absorção.
Você pode sim fazer um escaldapés, né,
com clorete magnésio.
E tem mais estudos do cloreto de
magnésio para conta de absorção pela
pele.
Não faz sentido gastar com magnésio
queelado porque para absorção pela pele
não vai ter nenhuma vantagem, além de
ser mais caro. Então, usa o clorete
magnésio. Sugestão, pega 150 g de
clorete magnésio, dilu em 5 L de água
morna e faça um escaldapés,
deixando os pés imersos por 15 a 20
minutos. Depois você seca, não enxaggua,
só seca.
E você pode fazer isso todas as noites
antes de dormir. Se você tiver diarreia,
é uma boa solução para você não ter que
ficar tomando vioral, um magnésio mais
caro.
Você pode mandar fazer também o magnésio
cloreto transdémico na farmácia
manipulação.
Tem pessoas que t pele muito sensível e
que pode ter irritação, tá? Então, fica
atento quanto a isso.
Agora, isso serve mais para quem não tem
deficiência grave de magnésio, tá? Se
você tiver deficiência leve, é uma boa
alternativa, mas a deficiência grave,
use via oral.
Boa noite, doutor. Poderia falar sobre
lipoproteína A LPA? É o marcador
genético. Sim, é um marcador genético,
tá? né? É uma partícula
de colesterol que é semelhante a LDL,
mas tem uma proteína extra chamado
apolipoproteína a junto.
A polipopproteína A geralmente ela é a
parte proteica do HDL, mas no caso de
quem tem LPA, essa poliproteína ela tá
ligada ao LDL, não ao HDL. Então essa
característica de ser uma partícula de
colesterol semelhante ao LDL ligado à
poliproteína A torna mais aterogênica,
ou seja, essa esse colesterol tem maior
potencial de entrar na parede da
artéria, inflamar e ao inflamar causar a
calcificação e causar entupimento da
artéria.
Então esse nível de LPA é determinado
pela genética. Infelizmente, os remédios
que nós temos na farmácia, um pouco tem
ação contra o LPA,
então é um macador genético, permanece
estável ao longo da vida,
não é alterado pela alimentação,
não é alterado por exercícios ou por
estilo de vida.
Existe protocolos aí que usam muita
coisa junto para tentar combater o LPA
para quem tem o LPA alto, mas é uma
situação bem difícil de tratar, é um
grande desafio.
OK?
Em 500 mg de magnésio glicina, quanto
tem de magnésio elementar? Essa
proporção é sempre fixa.
Bem, vamos lá.
Então, vocês já sabem que em 500 mg de
magnésio glicina, se você tá falando da
molécula inteira, você não vai ter 500
mg de magnésio elementar. Então, porque
a molécula que tá ligado ao magnésio é
maior do que o magnésio.
Então, conforme os dados técnicos, o
magnésio glicinato ou bisglicinato
de 500 mg contém aproximadamente 150 mg
de magnésio elementar. Então é 30% do
peso. Então se você tiver
pesos maiores, você faz a regra de três.
Então é sempre 30%. Então você pode
multiplicar por 0,3 o o volume para você
ter a quantidade do magnésio elementar.
Porém essa proporção não é completamente
fixa, mas você pode utilizar isso como
parâmetro, tá? 0,3
ou 30%.
Mas é interessante, se você tiver um
suplemento em casa, você checar o rótulo
do suplemento para ver qual o teor de
magnésio elementar declarado, se é
diferente desse que eu tô falando. E se
for manipulada, você entra em contato
com a farmácia para poder ter essa
informação.
Se não tiver essa informação, usa esse
número que eu tô te falando, 30%.
Qual o melhor exemplo para dosar
magnésio?
É o magnésio intraeleritrocitário ou é o
magnésio tá dentro da célula vermelha do
Emácia?
OK? O cérico, ele é ruim porque ele tá
medindo a parte do magnésio, tá fora da
célula, que é a parte menos importante.
Então o magnésio ele é um mineral que
fica mais intracelular. Então, o ideal
você medir ele dentro da célula e um
jeito de você fazer isso é através do
magnésio intraeletrocitário,
porque só cerca de 1% de todo o magnésio
do organismo vai tá dentro da do sangue,
tá?
Doutor, sobre vitamina D, sabemos que
deve estar junto com a K2. A pergunta é:
algumas fórmulas como a Central
Nutrition contém também as vitaminas A e
são as liposolúveis, né? Gostaria de
saber sua opinião, se não ver problema
ou se prefere somente D3 com K2. Não,
eh, as liposolúveis vão bem juntas, tá?
Não tem nenhum problema de você utilizar
elas juntas.
O que você não deve fazer é juntar as
vitaminas lipossolúveis com as
hidrossolúveis. Não é que é o proibido,
mas é mais conveniente você tomar as
lipossolúves juntas e as hidrossolíves
separadas juntas também.
Então, quando você coloca a vitamina A,
a vitamina A também ela faz parte da
matriz óssea, tá? E a vitamina E ela
acaba sendo o antioxidante que vai
proteger eh as outras vitaminas. Então,
é interessante juntar ela assim.
Agora, dessas vitaminas todas, a A é que
tem mais risco de hipervitaminosa. Então
tem que tomar cuidado quando for
associar a vitamina às outras, que você
não exagere na dose.
Boa noite. dando uma de uma em
suplementos
numa conceituada farmácia de
manipulação, dando uma, que quer dizer
dando uma ã fiquei observando os
rótulos, deve ser dando uma olhada, né?
E aí os valores percentuais diários das
poções, aí vi muitos com valores
percentuais de áreas por poção muito
superior a 100%.
Como é que é?
Exemplo ah sim, tá falando da dose, tá?
Exemplo, a vitamina B12, 412%
da porção diária. Como é que é isso?
Como funciona? É o seguinte, tá? A
pessoa que tá doente, ela não vai ter
uma necessidade de vitamina diferente da
RDA, tá? RDA é aquela
conta que o pessoal faz de necessidade
mínima diária
da vitamina para pessoas saudáveis.
Então é muito comum, por exemplo, você
vê uma RDA bem baixinha e na hora de de
tá suplementando a dose é bem maior.
Isso tá errado? Não, não tá errado,
porque essa pessoa tá doente e muitas
pessoas têm polimorfismo, têm defeitos
genéticos que não consegue absorver a
vitamina de maneira correta, tá?
Então não é porque tá acima do RDA ou do
valor diário recomendado, é que você vai
se intoxicar sempre.
A B12, por exemplo, muito segura em
doses mais altas, tá? A a maioria das
vitaminas E com raras exceções, é mais é
tomar cuidado com a vitamina A e com a
vitamina E na forma de DL alfa
tocoferol, tá? Desculpa. Na forma de
autocotoferol, alfotocoferol.
Então, eh, interessante, como você não
sabe detalhes genéticos de todo mundo, é
usar doses um pouquinho mais altas para
você passar por cima do problema dos
polimorfismos que diminui a absorção ou
diminui a bidisponibilidade de várias
vitaminas que são seguras em doses
altas, tá?
E lembrando também que algumas vitaminas
a gente usa como remédio megadose. O
caso da vitamina B3 que a gente usa para
controle de esquizofrenia ou para baixar
o colesterol. É o caso da vitamina D de
dado para doença autoimune em altas
doses. É o caso, por exemplo, da
vitamina B1 tiamina para para Parxon
para Alzheimer e doses altas, tá? Então
tem esse detalhe também.
Dout. Lan, boa noite. Eu mantenho os
meus níveis de vitamina D acima de 100,
aproximadamente 4 anos.
Suplementação, não recomendo isso, tá?
Eu acho que pode dar certo, mas é um
risco. Suplementação extra acompanhada
também da vitamina K2. Ok, já ajuda.
Magnésio, ótimo. Melhor, melhor ainda,
geralmente o de malato. No entanto, sei
da importância da vitamina A na formação
desse quarteto pra matriz óssea. Sim.
Ocorre que a vitamina A contróle da D, é
um hormônio que é um hormônio
esteroidal, é lipossolúvel. D e a A são
lipossolúveis, né? Mas realmente a
vitamina D é humano esteroidal. tem
razão. Eh, existe o risco de excesso. A
vitamina A é da das dessas daí é a mais
complicada. Em termos de dosagem, sempre
é a individualidade biológica que conta.
Sim, sim, sem dúvida. Mas uma doagem de
1000 microg por dia de quê? De vitamina
A poderia ser considerada segura.
A gente usa para vitamina A, mas é
unidades, né? Não é microgramas.
Ainda, se me permitir, com relação a K2,
200 microg seria ideal. 200 microg é
tranquila. K2 é muito segura. Agora, a
vitamina A, eu não usaria ela de maneira
discriminada. Tem que medir no sangue e
se você quiser tomar de maneira segura,
eu não passarei de 5.000 unidades por
dia, tá?
seria essa a minha resposta para isso.
Bem, olhando aqui eh em termos de
microgramas, porque eu tô mais
acostumado com unidades,
o que tá sendo dito é 900 microginol
para homens como limite e 700 microg
para mulheres, tá? Tá? Então não é 1000,
não. Seria nessa faixa de 700 a 900.
Mas aí acho que 1000 você não vai est na
faixa perigosa não, porque a tolerada
aqui, pelo que eu tô vendo, são 3.000
microg diários no máximo, né?
Mas é importante ver no sangue como é
que tá a vitamina A, viu? você fazer
isso,
porque tem que lembrar que tem vitamina
A no fígado. Se você consome fígado, tem
nos ovos, tem nos produtos láctos. Se
você consome produtos láctos,
tá bom?
Ah, um exemplo de se uma mulher tem
esquizofrenia leve, não fez diagnóstico,
mas tem sintomas,
ela não chega a ser incapaz, mas tem
problemas. O senhor com os exames
clínicos pode diagnosticar que alguma
substância no cérebro está faltando?
Depende.
Eh, se você tá falando do exames
clínicos de uma maneira mais abrangente,
porque às vezes o exame de sangue não
vai dar nenhuma informação sobre isso.
Agora, os organicos urinários vai dar
mais informação.
Então, lembrando que para psiquiatria
não existe um exame
específico para diagnosticar
esquizofrenia, OK?
Eles não fazem diagnóstico através de
exames de sangue, mas sim os exames de
ácidos orgânicos urinais pode ajudar
bastante e alguma deficiência pode
acontecer de cobre, de zinco, a pessoa
pode ter uma sistémina alta, tudo isso
tem que ser corrigido e vai ajudar no
tratamento da esquizofrenia, apesar de
não ser a cura, tá?
A próxima.
Qual é o tipo de colágeno? É bom paraas
juntas articulares. O colágeno
hidrolizado tipo dois, tá? E qual o tipo
do colágeno é bom pra pele? É o colágeno
ver e sol
da manipulação.
Farmácia que manipula a integritar.
OK.
Então, paraa pele, esse colágeno
verissol, a predominância dele é do
colágeno tipo um e do tipo três.
A medicina integrativa, sim, tem
ferramentas interessantes para atenuar
sintomas da esquizofrenia,
principalmente quando atuamos
precocemente.
Aqui eu já respondi
assim, na sua opinião, a medicina
integrativa tem suplementos capaz de
atenuar muito os sintomas da
esquizofrenia,
autismo,
verúce, esquizofrenia. Qual o que a mesa
integrativa menos tem meios de ajudar?
Eu acho que é mais fácil tratar a
esquizofrenia do que o autismo, viu?
Autismo
é um grande desafio,
mas os dois dá para ajudar sim.
Olha, o suplemento que a gente mais usa
para esizofrenia é a vitamina B3 em
altas doses, né? o a nicotinamida,
a vitamina C em altas doses, o zinco
também é muito utilizado,
ômega-3,
complexo B também, o NAC,
o autismo a gente pode utilizar os
ômega-3, também pode utilizar
probiótico, usar gaba, usar o magnésio.
O nautiso é muito importante fazer a
modulação do intestino.
Na sua opinião, doutora, três pessoas do
interior do Nordeste se consultarem com
você via internet. Sim, eu atendo via
internet. Teve uma época que eu parei de
atender, mas eu atendo via internet.
Você já envia logo a lista dos exames
ou só após a primeira consulta? Sim,
posso mandar lista dos exames antes da
consulta?
Hio passado a passo. Como é que é?
Não entendi esse final aqui, mas sim, eu
atendo online, sim. Tá, sem problema
nenhum. Deixa eu ver as perguntas ao
vivo. A gente pode
gastar mais alguns minutos aqui com as
perguntas ao vivo.
Cobrando você do vídeo de caldo de osso.
Como assim?
Eu já falei que tem vídeo de caldo de
osso no canal. Eu já mostrei para vocês
isso na live passada.
Tem sim. Tem dois vídeos de de caldo de
osso do canal Maria Helena, um que é
como fazer o caldo de ossos e outro
falando sobre modo geral de caldo de
osso. Só procurar lá no canal.
Hum.
Qual é a melhor forma de fazer
desparatização? Eu não gosto muito
desses protocolos malucos que o pessoal
tá fazendo por aí, não. Eu usaria
antiparasitário comum mesmo, como
ivimectina,
como nitasoxanida e albendazol, tá?
Qual que é a dose do zinco licarnosina
que deve se tomar no combate do HPore?
A dose é de 70 mg duas vezes ao dia. Tem
problema tomar quando se está fazendo
tratamento com altas doses de vitamina
D? Não tem problema.
Seja bem-vinda, Naomi. Seja muito
bem-vindo ao nosso grupo canal fechado.
As perguntas são feitas através do
formulário que a gente coloca disponível
toda semana no grupo do YouTube,
desculpa, no grupo do WhatsApp, mas eu
também coloco a eh esse formulário
dentro do
próprio YouTube. Quer ver? Deixa eu
mostrar para vocês aqui.
Eu vou entrar aqui no YouTube,
onde tem a parte de
onde tem lá os posts, né?
Conteúdo,
postagens,
ó. Então, tem duas maneiras de você ver
isso. Ou você vê dentro do YouTube nas
postagens, na comunidade fechada
ou você pode olhar dentro do grupo do
WhatsApp que fica fixado os comentários
em cima.
Deixa eu mostrar aqui,
ó. Tá mostrando já. no caso, né? Tá
aparecendo para vocês aí, ó. Tá vendo?
Então, tem aqui o post, ó, que eu
coloquei, né? Link da live fechada, foi
publicado só para membros dentro do
YouTube, na comunidade do YouTube. E
aqui tá o questionário, ó. Tá vendo? Foi
postado lá.
H.
Qual traz mais benefício pro intestino
inflamado? Corebione ou suco de babosa?
O corebiome
vai lá buscar o vídeo que tá lá já no
canal que eu acho que você não achou.
Então vamos lá, gente. A gente tá
criando agora dois níveis no na
comunidade. O nível anterior continua
valendo para todo mundo que está como
membro da comunidade fechada, que vai
ser essas lives semanais de terça-feira
à noite para tirar as dúvidas. E vai ter
a cada 15 dias uma live que até onde eu
sei vai ser de domingo. A gente pode
mudar esse dia, mas a gente vai fazer de
domingo a cada 15 dias para discutir
artigo. Então vai ser o segundo nível.
Quem quiser partir pro segundo nível é
só ir lá no Seja membro no YouTube e e
marcar lá para fazer parte do segundo
grupo, tá? que que é o segundo nível do
grupo de apoiadores. Eu eu fiz um vídeo
lá explicando sobre isso.
Ã, primeira vez na live. Gostaria de
saber o quê de da pergunta? Eh, como eu
já falei, tá? Acho que você escutou, né?
Boa noite a todos.
Quais exames fazer para descobrir a
causa da ferina elevada?
Tem que analisar um conjunto de exames.
Não é só um exame único, não, tá? Você
vê a saturação da transferrina,
você vê a capacidade de saturação, você
vê o ferro, a ferritina, vê a saúde
intestinal, vê outros marcadores para
ver se tem outros marcadores
inflamatórios aumentados, como é o caso
da proteína ser reativa. Vê se tem, por
exemplo, alteração na telucina se tiver
condição de fazer fator de necrose
tumoral alfa, pode ver também vhs. Tem
vários exames.
Qual que é a dosagem de área que
comidade de P5P? Tão de 30 a 50 mg por
dia, tá? Que é o peridoxal c fosfato.
Ah, isso, irma. Depois você assiste o
vídeo gravado, tá? Como faz para entrar
no grupo? Isso daí está lá dentro do
YouTube.
Lá no YouTube, quando você for ver lá os
benefícios que você tem do da
comunidade, tem lá os links. Quer ver?
Vou mostrar para vocês aqui, ó.
Pera aí, deixa eu fir a tela com vocês
aqui.
Aparece aqui grupo no WhatsApp e o link.
Tá
aqui, ó. Grupo no WhatsApp e o link.
Tá esse link aqui, tá vendo?
aparece para você, só você colocar lá
lives semanais.
Bem, eu vou colocar esse link aqui até
para você, para facilitar tua vida, tá?
Ó, clica nesse link aqui para entrar no
grupo do WhatsApp, Rodrigo.
OK.
Mas tá dentro lá do YouTube também.
Mais alguma pergunta, pessoal, que eu
vou encerrar, tá?
De nada, Rodrigo.
Bem, pessoal, muito obrigado pela
participação de vocês.
Vejo vocês na semana que vem. Um grande
abraço, um beijo no coração.